hi and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept of
biology in less than 5 minutes or so and
if you haven't here subscribed to my
channel hit that subscribe button and
please don't forget to leave your
comments below because that gives me
motivation now in this installment we'll
be talking about a genetic manipulation
technique which allow us to special
temporally control gene expression
especially in the mammalian system this
is called dead-on and tit off system and
in this whole video we'll be talking
about how we can use this system what is
the basis of the system and how the
system was discovered so let's just talk
about how this system is discovered
so as usual this system is a system
which is already present in the bacteria
and the scientist took the idea of
engineering this system from the
bacteria you know that there are several
bacterias which are anti bacterial which
are like antibiotic resistant some
bacterias which are tetracycline
resistant have a tetracycline resistance
gene let's say call it dead gene and
this tetracycline resistance gene is
under our Tet operator so this gene
ultimately give rise to a protein which
is like gene product of this tech gene
and what these protein does is just pump
out that antibiotic outside such that it
can create resistance against this
antibiotic right by imagine this system
is not always required for these
resulting resistant bacteria it is only
required on purpose when there is
tetracycline or antibiotic present in
the environment when there is no
antibiotic it's not required so let's
just imagine that there is no antibiotic
in the environment in that situation
there is a repressor gene present in the
same bacteria which is producing a
repressor protein and that is sitting on
the tit operator and repressing the
jeans or Ted open our system because at
that point of time the bacteria don't
need any resistance protein right and
making that protein would be waste of
the energy of the bacteria its energy
demanding process right in that
situation bacteria won't make it but
when there is a presence of antibiotic
in the environment bacteria would
produce this and to produce these Ted
gene products that that would allow him
to get bacterial resistance now looking
at this system scientists always thought
how they can use this system so they
designed a system which they can use it
to manipulate the gene expression in a
special and a temporal manner special
means where and temporal mean when in
terms of gene expression these two where
and when is the most important thing and
this particular system the Ted want a
tone system gives us a hold on when so
it takes care about the temporal aspect
of the gene expression or the gene
manipulation so the temporal aspect is
generally taken care of the date on Tate
of system now let's talk about the
system directly so here is the target
gene so this target gene could be the
gene of interest and whose expression we
wanted to study and the consequence of
expression we wanted to study in the
cell or in a physiological situation but
we don't want this gene to be expressed
for all that time we want it to be
expressed when we want it to be
expressed so in order to temporally
control it expression we need to we need
to have a system where we have a
temporal handle so let's just talk about
the system first so you have the target
gene which is your gene of interest
under a minimal promoter D marked here
in green which could be a CMV promoter
as well now you have another it
responsive element several reputation of
Tetris prot and responsive element where
actually our TTA can bind now what are
TTA does
is basically folding of the situation
and looping of the DNA in presence of
tetracycline and it can interact with
the RNA polymerase which is sitting in
the minimal promoter and really induce
its expression from the promoter
I mean gene expression from the promoter
by control by interacting with the RNA
polymerase so it on system is a system
where you can switch on the gene
expression when you give tetracycline
whenever tetracycline is present gene
expression would be there so it's a
customized switch on system and the key
player in this system is RT ta so RT ta
binds with the tetracycline and it
allows to interact allows the region to
interact with the DNA polymer and RNA
polymerase and thereby it can transcribe
the downstream gene there is another
system which is called it off system
here putting tetracycline would prevent
the transcription from the downstream
gene or downstream motor so here what
happens is the tetracycline trans
activator which is a different protein
it can bind to a normal responsive
element and in presence of tetracycline
or doxycycline what happens it cannot
interact with the RNA polymerase and
thereby the gene expression is off right
so this kind of system could be useful
where the gene is normally expressed and
you want the gene to be special
temporarily shut down you want it to
shut down at the time that you want in
that kind of situation tetracycline off
system is important so here is a quick
summary in Daytona Tate of system both
the systems are used to space your
temper temper orally and spatially
regulate gene expression but one is to
activate the gene and one is to stop the
gene expression so tit off is for
stopping the gene expression data oils
for activating the gene expression
now we should talk about how exactly in
the laboratory you can do the data on
tear of genes and how does it work so
definitely if you want to do it in in
vitro situation let's say in cell
culture so you have a gene so you have a
gene of interest which is cloned in a
Tet Klaus mint or Tet on class made
let's say so in that plasmid you would
have the tetracycline response element
and other classmate would be the vector
coding for tetracycline trans activator
now you have to collect operate those
construct or transmit those construct
inside the cells and you played the
cells after plating the cell whenever
you want to switch ON or switch off the
gene based on the system you are using
either tat on or tip off you have to add
tetracycline or doxycycline to it by
addition of tetracycline or doxycycline
let's say you're using a Tec on system
you can switch on the gene expression
and it is totally in your hand in your
control when you want this gene to be
expressed it is specially important for
many genes which are important for
development if you perturb those genes
during the development the whole sale
might die the organism might I might die
so in order to study the role of gene in
a specific time frame this kind of
system could be really handy now what
would happen inside the cell when it is
transfected the vector that having the
tre and the gene of interest would would
be there and the vector coding our TPA
or TPA would be expressing the RTT a
protein and which would allow the
transcription to happen from the
downstream target gene by interacting
with the RNA polymerase and that is how
a tetete on system orchid off system can
work in a cell culture based method now
it is not only limited to in vitro
situation it is also can be used in in
vivo situation for example if we talk
about Mouse genetics now there are eight
on and tre mouse intead on Mouse there
would be tissue specific promoter and
thereby the spatial aspect so the
tetracycline TR are
TAF would be specifically expressed in
the tissue of my interest because it is
under a tissue specific promoter and
another mouse where that result clean
response element would be there and it
would have our gene of interest
downstream to it now we have to cross
these two minds and in the f1 progeny we
would have a tissue specific spatial and
temporal controlled genetic manipulation
so this would give us a great handle to
understand the function of gene or
protein in a way better in a better
manner so I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and don't forget to leave your
comments below thank you